[Music]
stranger things co-stars a joke kiri and
Natalia dire stepping out together for
Audi's Prix Emmys party in Los Angeles
on Thursday night fun weekend for you
too
what's your favorite thing about
stepping out together for all of these
events we got like a buddy that you can
just owe their show is up for some big
awards Sunday and we're just about a
month away from season two three things
we can expect from that first episode of
season two oh gosh it's gonna be scary
it's gonna be fulfilling and it's gonna
be worth the wait is that good I'll take
a are we getting any bar but references
in season two yes actually and I think
the first I don't think I can say
anything that's justice for bar yeah
what things changed between season one
and season two would you kind of know
these people know so it's it's you know
you don't have to establish as much so I
think it's kind of darker murkier
it's exciting I don't know even I you
know shot the whole thing and was still
excited just watching it so yeah jump in
here bigger us a hater
he got to watch the first couple have
you seen them as well watch them but
purposefully I yet I really kind of
wanted I wanted to wait um you know
until it actually comes out and like
have the whole I don't to be a part of
that like you know anticipation and
excitement binge with everybody
exactly I mean I don't know that's the
thing is like I'm not much of a Binger I
kind of like those space things take
your time
savor a little bit yeah you know I don't
mind it but you know definitely have
that kind of like waiting period I don't
know I didn't want to be like privilege
not I mean I'm gay I'm very I'm not no
no I'm very excited